wir werden auf den soldaten durch
hexerei ist der neue film des regisseurs
der auch schauspieler ist mel gibson und
es ist die wahre geschichte von des
mentors das war ein soldat das heißt
eigentlich nur ein sanitäter der im
zweiten weltkrieg ohne waffe aufs
schlachtfeld spaziert ist weil er gleich
ein tief religiöser mensch wahr er keine
waffe antworten darf wurde versichert
ich muss keine waffe tragen vertreten
ich habe mich gerade
aber nachdem an der woche gesehen hat
was die achsenmächte also anstellen
hatte gesagt okay das ist definitiv vom
teufel dagegen sich irgendwas tun also
isst die pazifische front gezogen und
hat dort ohne waffe als sanitäter in
einer nacht über 70 seiner landsleute
gerettet also unter leichenbergen
vorgezogen und an den rand dieser des
hochplateaus gefärbt wie dort abgesagt
andernfalls wären sie gestorben
mit diesem feld auf dem sich die
handlung abspielt imex oric hat gibson
jetzt sozusagen ein neues bild gefunden
nämlich einst von in der schwebe seien
zwischen abgrund also hölle und gerettet
werden also himmel und dieses
alttestamentliche nicht passt ganz gut
diese schlachten topographie dieser
schlachten logik dieser schlachten
ästhetik
der zug kommt arbeit dass die
widerlichkeit die man dreimal gibt
manchmal finden kann in diesem programm
hier passiert ist zurückgenommen ist in
der gestalt dieses mannes der eben
unbewaffneter hingeht und das ist eine
tolle metapher für die verantwortung von
einzelnen menschen in situationen die
eigentlich viel größer sind historisch
grauenhaft für den vater kirchen sind
katastrophen bin ich habe meine boden
stand gesehen wusste nicht mehr die
wende
wir haben wir unser land mehr geleistet
dass auch nur irgendjemand leisten kann
ich habe mich in meinem ganzen leben
noch nie so genannte menschen getäuscht
ich hoffe eines tages das aller aller
aller aller allerbeste an den film sind
zwei schauspieler
das eine ist luca fiel der auch schon
oscar nominiert ist dafür und der
wahrscheinlich einer der
intelligentesten jungschauspieler ist
wenn man intelligent ablesen kann daran
wie viele vereine wieder straßen man ihn
beispielsweise mimik unterbringen kann
und das andere andere aller allerbeste
ist der andere schauspieler hugo weaving
der hier den vater spiel der sanden
erster bietet in den krieg ziehen und
dann um seinen sohn bittet als der vom
gericht steht weil eine grundausbildung
nicht schießen will und das ist eine
sehr zerrissene kaputte gebeugte
durchgeknetet und gleichzeitig würde
volle figur die der wie winter abgibt
alle anderen meisten auch gericht aber
nicht alle anderen klar weil alle
anderen schweißen sich daran denken mich
weihnacht genauso wie meine kumpel und
ich werden und die soldaten die
überlebenden das nur weiter so manchem
standest du nicht was ich glaube es gibt
drei gruppen die sich hauptsächlich für
den film interessieren werden das eine
sind leute die kriegsfilme mögen das
andere sind leute die krieg firma
hartmann das dritte sind leute den fixen
egal sind
die dritte gruppe wird interessiert
werden an dem stoff die zweite gruppe
wird ihre vorteile gegen den krieg die
urteile gegen den krieg sind bestätigt
finden und die erste gruppe h die
klingen halten haufen marian um die
ohren geschlagen und noch was denken sie
das recht zugesprochen in den kampf zu
ziehen ohne eine waffe zu tragen
sie dürfen ihren dienst weiter ausüben
[Musik]